this movie is [ __ ] awesome
and i have nothing but positive things
to say uh i love
i think the reason i love this movie so
much is james gunn's script
it constantly takes these left turns
when you're not expecting them
can you both talk about what you loved
about the script and what you're excited
for fans to see
i am a young actor and uh with the
with the time like i sometimes i
couldn't
see if a script was good or bad or
medium with with this script i felt
right away that i had a masterpiece in
my hands it has violence
it has smart humor and dark humor
it has uh emotional scenes
it has a lot of content and it has
amazing characters that
nobody ever heard about them but now
they
pray for them to survive so for me like
i i'm like it blew my mind and for me
james is really a genius i think james
has
definitely got uh an imagination
that just excites
the you know a true fan you know someone
that sort of read the comics and
someone's got their
history you know you imagine that james
is going to do the work and bring to get
bring to visualization
something that is special uh and i knew
that and that was really exciting for me
i love learning about stuff that um you
don't know about the making of a movie
for both of you what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
actual making of the film
the actuality you know there was so much
stuff that james
built um you know practical sets
um with a lot of detail um
you know foul you know literally
hundreds and hundreds of extras
and big crowd scenes you know
wide shots that were really real and not
just cgi
so i think people you know be surprised
by that yeah and real bullets
actually i have bullets in in my home
uh that i took from from there yeah
from the start that's that's really
funny uh
uh idris i have to ask you an individual
question just because i'm a huge fan of
george miller
and i believe you just worked with him
recently can you uh can you talk about
what it was like working with him in
that project
uh it was amazing working with george
he's um
a g like you know one of the godfathers
of filmmaking
modern day filmmaking and storytelling
and uh this is a project that was really
close to his heart so i was really
honored to be asked and
to work with tilda swinton it was it was
perfect
i cannot wait listen again
congratulations to both of you this
movie is so awesome
uh i hope it's a huge hit thank you so
much for your time thank you so much